welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Star
Wars Rebels season 4 the final season
and the conclusion to our four-part
Rebels re-watch series to give viewers
of Ahsoka the Mandalorian and other Star
Wars live action titles a bit of a cheat
sheet to know the most important names
Easter eggs and pieces of lore from the
animated Rebels series while season 4
was down to 16 episodes from 22 every
moment of this final run was so good and
worthy of watching but here is a recap
and breakdown of the most crucial
details and please enjoy this whole
Rebels recap series as a companion to
our Ahsoka breakdowns and he can support
us with an Ahsoka fulcrum shirt and nerd
riot.shop okay here we go episodes one
and two Heroes of Mandalore on the
planned Mandalore Sabine leads her clan
ran on a rescue mission for her father
Empire loyal mandalorians are led by
tybersacks and brother to Gar Saxon so
this final season opens with the rebels
retaking one of their homeworlds
Mandalore and it ends with a sort of
liberation of lothal Ezra's home making
this whole season a full homecoming
Sabine has a new jet pack with purple
wings and still carries a dark saber
after c season 3 episode 11 visions of
voices saw her possessed by a night
sister ghost on dathomir and take it
from Maul's Temple and Kane and trained
her with this saber and trials of the
darksaber but it does remain a cursed
artifact that she doesn't really want
Sabine is saved by bocaton Crees Katie
Sackhoff is returning from Clone Wars
but she also doesn't want the darksaber
initially Ezra's uncertain jetpack play
this episode is modeled on art for The
Rocketeer directed by Joe Johnston who
did the original jetpack designs for
Boba Fett these Rebels learned that war
with the Empire has erased their want
for leadership even Once Upon a Time
these planes were covered with grass and
it never grew back never had a chance to
this is what continuous War has done to
my home Mandalore was initially scorched
after an ancient war with the Jedi but
further Fusion by Arms by mob Gideon
that will take place after this we'll
turn this surface into Rocky glass we'll
see this in the Mandalorian season three
yet vegetation will begin to grow in
caves and a mythosar will appear in the
Living Waters but again this is set
before those bombings happen the
Mandalorian capital city of tsundere is
still standing its domed appearance
actually came from the design
development for Clone Wars George Lucas
suggested to use a trackball mouse as a
starting point Andrew Casino voices
Captain hark after being the original
voice of Saw Guerrera and Clone Wars
sagarrera in this Show's Voice by Boris
Whitaker from Rogue one their attack on
the transport was inspired by the truck
Chase and Raiders of the Lost Ark and
the tank Chase and Last Crusade Sabine
uses purple paint to Blind the driver
the power of Art in action later on this
season they'll use spray paint to get
the upper hand on Rook the Assassin and
this artistic Flair is something that
Sabine actually gets from her father
Ulrich your design aesthetic is still
derivative of the pre-exile Mastiff
tojin was an influence obviously but I
made it my own Ursa and Tristan's group
gets wiped out by a laser that vaporizes
wearers of beskar armor something that
Sabine we learned design during her time
with the Empire they call this weapon
The Duchess after bocaton's sister
Duchess sateen which just feels doubly
cruel for the Mandalorian people even
thrawn seems uncertain about concrete
mandalorians with such cruelty showing
that he understands the importance of
respecting ancestral heritage this is
the first time the Mandalorian armor is
referred to as beskar in Canon it was
first mentioned in Star Wars Rebel
Commando hard contact the original idea
for the episode actually was to have
Sabine Knight her mandalorians with the
darksaber leaving scorches on their
armor so really the dark side of her is
more of a paintbrush than it is a weapon
Sabine hands off the darksaber to Boca
tan craze in this episode and Boca Town
uses it to unite all the Mandalorian
factions I accept this sword for my
sister for my clan
and for all of Mandalore
but Sabine says that the saber came to
her so that she could pass it to bocaton
and I look at that the way diseases work
viruses curses these things exist so
that the host can transmit them as far
as possible alright episode 3 and 4 in
the name of rebellion we see the Gavin 4
base in the masasi temple which of
course was first seen in matte paintings
in the original 1977 Star Wars this is
Chopper's first time here ahead of his
live-action cameo in Rogue one when the
ghost crew will actually join the Battle
of scarif sagarera appears that Rebel
extremists matching his appearance in
Rogue one when his gray hair has grown
in yet he still has his legs these
episodes so those injuries plus the
breathing apparatus he'll need to use
those happen after this his massive
Hollow projection literally talks down
to Monmouth but she stands her ground
and snaps if we degrade ourselves to the
Empire's level what will we become this
line mirrors what sargerara will tell
jyn urso in Rogue one what will you
saws you Wing arrives to help it is the
same black and white partisan markings
that we see it have on Jed hot in row
one they find a group of Engineers from
Coruscant being shipped to Jetta and a
giant Kuiper Crystal referring to the
collaborators of Galen urso that were
shipped from corsan to IDU in Rogue one
and the Crystal Bean what the Empire
wanted to use to power the Death Star
superlaser Ezra senses this at first by
hearing the crystal as a song which I
believe links his force abilities with
the song of the pergol hyperspace whales
the crystal explodes releasing a green
Shockwave evoking in the detonation of
the Star Wars super laser like we saw
kyber crystals exploding in season 1
episode 6. all right episode 5 the
occupation Sabine has now updated her
look with darker hair and she keeps her
the rest of the season until the
epilogue Monmouth calls the planet
lothal and I just really appreciate how
filoni does this even though it's lothal
just recalling the planet's
pronunciation from the series pilot
episode and kind of like mixing up
calling atat's at ads and Walkers he
just kind of makes room for everyone's
pronunciation and shuts down those
Gatekeepers like to um actually people
in the comments that said Pergo is
singular emperor world you don't say per
goals that's just basic human decency
okay vizago returns getting traded some
puffer pigs returning from season one
with some piglet versions these designs
were made for the season one Lando
episode but scrapping that episode they
come back here they're a lot of fun both
all's ecology we learned has been
scorched it's grasslands have been wiped
out echoing some beans lament over
mandalore's ecological transformation
thank God we do see a straight look at
in an alley also some wanted posters of
the specters lining the walls using
their photos from their season 1 and 2
appearances this is when they were outed
at the Old Joe's Bar from Empire day the
bartender is now Imperial pilot bailin
Rooter returning from season one when he
was given the parade armors the
hollownet screen ticker and orbish reads
farewell and then 2-1 Chloe dirkness
elicious and Sammy have left the
building must be some kind of in-joke
with the animators jaikel returns Colin
Ezra Oleg which was the name of the
loyal Imperial Cadet who nearly spoiled
Ezra's undercover mission in the
breaking ranks episode jaikel now on
Ahsoka serves as a senator on lothal
with Governor writer Azadi episode 6
Flight of the defender three adorable
low cats hop up next to Ezra and he
cannot help but smile at these
celestials gifts from mortis giving them
well-deserved scratchy scratches now the
sound of the cats are actually
recordings from sound designer David
accord's cat text they see the new Thai
Defender which is given a new color
scheme a reshaped rear engine a
hyperdrive unit and the wings now
actually pop off and the style of the
Kenner Tie Fighter toys thrawn arrives
to inspect these and Ezra sees on the
hill his first loath wolf there's an
animated Dolly zoom on Ezra in this
moment because these are extremely
important we actually saw depictions of
loath wolves in the lothal Jedi Temple
art in season one and two and Ezra says
while they haven't been seen in 100
years here they are Ezra follows a white
loath cat to safety kind of like the
white rabbit from Alice in Wonderland as
Ezra's Journey with the animals of
lothal does take him through a Looking
Glass a larger loath wolf greets Ezra
and takes him to safety I don't
understand why did you help us
Doom now at first we think it's Doom
d-o-oom but it's actually Doom d-u-m-e
as in Caleb Doom Kanan jairus's original
name but both homophones right now leave
us with an ominous feeling episode 7
Kindred thrawn dispatches an assassin
named Rook you'll remember the word work
as the shutdown command for thrawn's
Droids in season 3 but the character of
Rook was thrawn's bodyguard in Timothy
zahn's 1991 heir to the Empire who
eventually turned on thrawn and
assassinated him but not here now
Timothy Zahn wanted rook's species to be
called Sith to justify Darth Vader's
title of Lord of the Sith but later
lucasfilm would establish the Sith as a
dark side cult opposed to the Jedi so
instead he's called a nogiri and the
notary skull does sort of resemble the
helmet of Darth Vader here he's voiced
by long time lucasfilm actor Warwick
Davis Loth wolves lead them into caves
and Sabine Cece's cave drawings of the
loath wolves as constellations like the
path to paridia closing credits in
Ahsoka which I translated every single
Rune in in another video definitely go
watch that it's gonna be one of those
useful videos you can watch for Ahsoka
the both wolves then lead them in this
Force imbued path now we'll see more of
this realm later but remember back in
season 2 episode 1 Minister Tua before
her death hinted at a real reason the
empire was interested in lothal and this
is it folks but even more interestingly
cave paintings depict Jedi descending
from space case one of these is a tall
pointy head likely kiadi Mundi we also
see Yoda with this lightsaber on his
Hilt not just the Oda species this is a
Jedi Yoda and then a third figure a
human beside them I assume this is Mace
Windu and then the Jedi child hovers
over them so the Assumption since then
has been that this depicts these three
Jedi bringing a young Caleb Doom to the
lothal Jedi Temple as a young lady and
that is how he got the name Doom because
these cave drawings are thousands of
years old this would have been something
that was predicted thousands of years
prior the whole idea of this episode is
Kanan and Ezra are Kindred through the
force connected to lothal through the
threads of Fate episode 8 crawler
commandeers mining Guild or crawlers
burn up the lothal grasslands now these
designs came from the world Devastators
these were flying automated factories
from 1991 Legends comic series dark
Empire Captain sever listens to the same
music that Zed lessons do back in the
season 2 episode The Mystery of Chopper
base the slave master that Zeb fights
its named approach anatu Pat Roach The
Stunt actor who bought Indiana Jones in
the first three Indie movies though his
scene was removed from Last Crusade and
then after decoding the schematics to
the Thai Defender Elite tariff pushes
the rebels to strike the Imperial
Factory on lothal big mistake episode 9
Rebel assault Mark Matton from the iron
Squadron episode returns as a pilot
inhera's group and on his helmet is
Sammy and orabash these x-wings you'll
notice are painted green but they are
not part of a green Squadron they're
just part of Hera's Phoenix Squadron
here but other than a more recent
appearance of an X-Wing in and or season
one this I think would be the earliest
chronological appearance of x-wings
ahead of their use in the Battle of
scarif in Rogue one and the Battle of
Gavin in A New Hope their build is
slightly tweaked to match the
proportions of the 1978 toy but the Thai
Defender Elites just wipe out these
x-wings had this tie Defender program
been expanded there would just be no way
the rebels would have made it through
the Death Star Trench Run the Empire
would not have lost the Galactic Civil
War episode 10 Jedi Knight opens with
price torturing Hera and thrawn brings
back in here is calicori and sails out a
single bead for a brother who died in
the past as Ezra senses from the tower
for Hera we see some lost bats which
flew to the city from the Empire's
ecological destruction in so they kind
of made a mistake there because it
creates an opening for the rebels to
sneak in with these gliders Kanan uses a
knife to cut his hair a ritual that we
see Sabine Wren do in Ahsoka Tarkin
tells thrawn your Thai Defender program
is at risk Orson krennic has been quite
persuasive about diverting the funding
to his own project
taught us yeah of course he's referring
to critics Death Star project so again
it's the Quick Fix of the Death Star
that defunded the harder to eradicate
offensive Hardware that the Empire would
have been Invincible with the Thai
Defenders I also like this detail
because it's clear that Tarkin initially
was super skeptical a project Stardust
but as soon as it was effective he took
all the credit for it away from krennic
Harris says I have to tell you something
[Music]
her hair now we've already seen them
kiss so yeah I don't think she just
wants to say I love you I think another
calicori beat is on the way here they
fly down to pick up Kanan and Hera but
price uses a walker to fire on the fuel
pod and Kanan uses the force to repel
the Flames his other hand to push back
Hera to the ship no words are exchanged
here just observe and weep
thank you
interesting how kanan's Force projection
is tinted blue like his lightsaber and
it's pretty rare to see a manipulation
of heat and energy and chemical
reactions like this it's not common to
see this in Star Wars kylo Ren did
suspend a blaster bolt in the force
awakens and of course grogu pulled off a
very similar move in the Mandalorian
season 3 finale we are left this episode
in heartbreak the closing title is
rendered in Bleak charred Ash episode 11
Doom as Hera Morin's Chopper holds her
hand just like he did to Kanan when
Kanan was first Blinded in the season 2
finale Ezra meets the Doom wolf which
has on its head the same symbol that
Kanan had on his shoulder armor and the
credits of the episode Dave filoni
credited the voice of the Doom wolf as
played by quote the force but it does
kind of sound like Freddie Prince Jr as
the wolf is kind of an embodiment of the
force through kanan's essence
passed
past redeem
future
the Wolves give Ezra this stone with
three hands one closed one from an open
another relaxed and open this Stone will
show up actually in Lutheran rael's shop
in Andor and we will see the Stone's
importance in episode 12 wolves in a
door they ride a pack of loath wolves to
the lothal Jedi Temple and as they
descend into the Tall Grass Tara
experiences some flashbacks to Major
Kane and Jarrett's moments from
throughout the series with lines from
spark of rebellion path of the Jedi
vision of Hope fire across the Galaxy
and Siege of lothal they also use a
recording of thrawn from the season 3
finale zero hour to distract the Scout
Troopers and steal their helmets helmets
that we might see in the back of
sabine's room in Ahsoka we meet Varys
Hayden voiced by Malcolm McDowell and
advisored Palpatine and a scholar of the
Jedi and Sith lore a part originally
meant to be served by Von a Vader's
assistant in Rogue one but here Haydn
speaks of Palpatine who course is voiced
by Ian McDermott symbols and iconography
a reminiscent of a report I discovered
in the Jedi archives
the mortise Gods okay the mortise Gods I
think we might do a whole other video
just in the mortis Arc but I'm gonna
give you a quick recap here the mortise
gods are from the Clone Wars Ark in
season 3 episode 15 16 and 17. they are
the Father the daughter and the son and
yes they are essentially the Holy
Trinity of the Star Wars Universe
technically they are considered
celestials in Star Wars lore yes there
are celestials in Marvel but there are
also celestials in Star Wars the sun
represents the dark side of the force
the daughter represents the light side
of the force and the father represents
the balance between so in this Arc
Obi-Wan Ahsoka and Anakin end up in the
realm of mortis and they find these
three figures the father actually tells
Anakin to stay with them in mortis
because he is the chosen one the sun
takes Ahsoka captive to try to force
Anakin to join him in overpowering the
father and the daughter a lot of
goes down but when the sun is about to
kill the Father the daughter sacrifices
herself to save the father and transfers
her life force to Ahsoka and this
connection is represented from here
forward in the form of ahsokas bird Mori
next the sun shows Anakin future visions
of himself as Vader and Anakin ricked
out about what might come next decides
to join the sun briefly but the father
ends up erasing Anakin's memory and
kills himself with a sword to take his
son's power away allowing Anakin to kill
the sun it is crazy just watch these
three episodes you'll see what I mean
summer is almost over but Wanderlust
lasts forever and you can use Babel to
be prepared for your next trip no matter
what season it is Babel is one of the
top language learning apps in the world
it is scientifically proven to help you
start speaking a new language in just
three weeks Babel's lessons are designed
by real language teachers your
subscription even comes with two free
live classes Babel's method is simple it
teaches you real world conversation so
you're prepared to have practical
conversations about travel business
relationships and more you can use it to
get a real experience no matter where
you go with phrases like
a Babel subscription might be what you
need if you're really in love with the
language get a lifetime subscription if
you're just flirting with a poor in
tongue there are monthly options
available as well no matter what you
need Babel has you covered click the
link in the description or scan the QR
to get 60 off your Babel subscription
today so Ezra and Sabine recognized the
three hands from the stone the fist for
the sun firm hand for the father and the
relaxed hand for the daughter Sabine
makes the connection of the three hands
just as she makes the connection with
the three faces of the night sister star
map in Ahsoka here she says the painting
on the temple is like a star map but
none that I'm familiar with those lines
are like paths and the Rings are planets
or or doorways the lines are like paths
and the Rings are planets or doorways we
see the same thing in the path to
peridia's star map in Ahsoka especially
in the closing credits the golden line
represents the path in the golden rings
represent planets again watch that video
where I break down all the runes and
what all those planets mean Ezra places
his hand on the relaxed daughter hand
and the ring lights up in the doorway
reconfigures and Ezra follows the loath
wolves as they walk in a ring forming a
portal bringing the stew episode 13 a
world Between Worlds I'm telling you it
is the most impo Jordan episode of this
series throughout this episode we hear
famous lines from Star Wars history
first Yoda this is from Attack of the
Clones
Yoda speaking of Obi-Wan in the Jedi
Temple when they were looking for kamino
on the star map oh they wonderful the
mind of a child is I think we'd leave
with this because Yoda is respecting how
wonderful Ezra's young mind is for
discovering this next Obi-Wan and
Qui-Gon from Clone Wars part of the
mortis Arc overlords what is this place
what is this place
unlike any other a conduit for which the
entire force of the universe flows ah
what Qui-Gon described then is what we
are seeing now next Yoda in Empire
Strikes Back which happens after this
luminous being silly not this crude
matter he's speaking to Luke In This
Moment a way of saying we are beings
made of light in the force we are not
just blood bone and muscle next Ahsoka
in season two of rebels
just when you think you understand the
force
[Music]
Ezra and now we're
just far more complex than any of us
thought next Yoda in Revenge of the Sith
train yourself to let go
of everything you fear to lose now very
important advice for Ezra in this realm
next Obi-Wan in the season 3 episode
twin Sons
unfortunately
what you need you already have
unfortunately you seem to be letting it
all go which old Ben said to Ezra and
also seems to respond to Yoda's previous
line next Kanan and Rebels
let him lose his way
like I won't let him lose his way not
like I did showing how kanan's guidance
is still with Ezra even now okay so Ezra
walks through the world Between Worlds
this is a realm in which the force
connects all of time and space next we
hear a very important line
created by all living things
penetrates us it binds the Galaxy
together this is of course Alec Guinness
Obi-Wan and A New Hope a conversation
with Luke that has not happened yet the
force as well gives the Jedi his power
it's an energy field created by all
living things it surrounds us and
penetrates us it binds the Galaxy
together now more come a bit later
they're all kind of mixed together
[Music]
so you heard three there there was Yoda
in Revenge of the Sith Josh for those
around you who transform into the force
there was mods Kanata to Rey in the
force awakens way in the future from now
I see your eyes
you already know the truth and cheered
in way in Rogue one the Force is with me
and I am with the force and then right
after this we actually hear jyn urso
from Rogue one
the time to fight is now and then the
voice of kylo Ren from the force awakens
interspersed with Rey whispering in the
force awakens
and then some words from the father to
Anakin in the mortise episode of
overlords
and now you see who we truly are then
Poe Dameron Whispering from the force
awakens
the resistance
then the dying words of the daughter an
altar of mortis
it is his nature then Maz Kanata again
for the force awakens
the belonging you seek is not behind you
and then Leia in A New Hope
this is our most desperate hour then
Yoda and Revenge of the Sith
the shadow of greed that is and then
Leia finishing her line from A New Hope
and then Anakin and Clone Wars telling
Ahsoka
you never would have made it as
Obi-Wan's Padawan so Ezra finds the more
I bird taking Ezra to a portal Through
Time back to ahsoka's duel with Vader on
malachor in the rebel season 2 finale we
never saw exactly how that duel ended
and now we see what happened Vader is
just about to kill her but Ezra pulls
her out of time Ezra up until this
moment had thought Ahsoka was dead so he
thought in this moment he changed
history to save her not realizing that
she was always alive so he mistakenly
runs away from Ahsoka to try to find
Kanan and we actually hear some voices
from Kanan like here
this was the moment he revealed himself
as a Jedi in the season 1 early episodes
good I'm about to let everyone in on the
secret then a line overheard by Ezra
from Kanan to Hera and the season 2
premiere
I survived one more
I'm not ready for another one then Kanan
in the season three episode about Rex's
Clone Wars memories
battles leave scores
some of you can't see and I love that we
hear this line here because battles
leaving scars is evidence that those
battles happen that you can't change
history to erase the scar you have to
keep the scar with you and sometimes you
can't see it it's just something you
have to carry with you that is the point
of life experience and we cannot erase
or evade or sidestep that life
experience but Ezra returns to the
moment of kanan's death on the Fuel
Depot and Ahsoka says that Kanan needed
to die so that the others could live
then the emperor calls out to them
mine at last now this blue flame on the
pedestal appeared in Clone Wars season 6
when Yoda went to moriband and the
emperor tried to corrupt his mind
through his connection with Count Dooku
it's just super creepy that the emperor
can see through time this way using a
Sith sorcery the emperor says
the way Ian McDermott says help me
recalls how he said it to Anakin after
Mace Windu scarred him in Revenge of the
Sith
so Ahsoka ends up going back through her
portal to the aftermath of her duel with
Vader in the season 2 finale when she
limped out of that Sith temple on
malachor with Mori this is actually the
episode we learned mori's name and in
Greek mythology the more I spelled
differently were the name of the three
Fates Ezra presses his hand against the
Fist of the Sun and we hear some of his
words from the mortar Stark and Clone
Wars and Ezra passes out and the temple
collapses now felony has said that he
doesn't think of the world Between
Worlds as time travel that instead it's
about gaining knowledge of the future
and as the doomwolf says restore the
past redeem the future so again Ezra has
already changed the past that is how
Ahsoka was already alive so in a sense
he just kind of closed the loop He
restored the past and by learning to
move on from Kanan Jairus death he has
redeemed the future and learned a lesson
about sacrifice to save your friends
that said the Ahsoka series at least now
seems to be flirting with the idea of
calling to people people through time
and referencing the Loth Wolves and the
gods of mortis so the world Between
Worlds episode is essential watching all
right episode 14 of Fool's hope Hera Rex
and kallus recruit Hondo Gregor and wolf
and ketsu from silos Ryder pretends to
betray the rebels to price who attacks
their cave dwelling but it was Ryder's
ruse to lure price out of her protection
of the capital and Ezra gets back up
from the loathe wolves it kind of
recalls the large fernok that appeared
behind Ezra in the season one episode on
an axis but now Ezra is fully in control
which brings us to the finale episodes
15 and 16 family reunion and farewell
this episode actually begins it's kind
of a hoped for family reunion between
Ezra and his parents showing a point of
vulnerability for Ezra that we'll see
later in this two-part finale the rebels
used price to infiltrate the Imperial
based on lothal and Ryder Azadi pulls an
Ezra to impersonate Admiral you Lauren
to order protocol 13 to Evac the base
but Rook has alerted thrawn who arrives
in the Chimera The Shield generator has
capacitors that look like the design in
the indoor bunker in Return of the Jedi
which are actually just stacked cups
that was what provide right at the seal
for the Death Star 2 while it was under
construction thrawn begins blasting
civilian sections of lothal and Ezra
confronts thrawn alone and leaves his
lightsaber behind with chopper and
Sabine gives Ezra a knowing look while
she distracts the others to let him go
you gotta imagine she carries a bit of
guilt with her in thrawn's quarters he
is framed perfectly between the islamiri
the lizards from Air to the Empire which
are Force immune which is just kind of
ironic that he has these two forced
immune creatures that are on either side
of him when he is not immune to the
forces of nature he also notice he still
has his Jedi guard mask on his desk
thrawn and Palpatine we learn have
removed parts of the lothal Jedi Temple
to the Chimera and inside Ezra sees his
mother calling to him just as aunt baru
called to Luke and twin sons thrawn and
Palpatine are essentially doing good cop
bad cop and Palpatine says you know it
is possible to change fate Palpatine
knows Ezra knows it's possible because
he saw him in the world Between Worlds
as Ezra destroys the temple he Sprints
through Palpatine's Hollow projection as
it flickers into his true form of Darth
Sidious and we hear the emperor's theme
Hera and the others get the lothal
shield back online and the ghost arrives
with a vast pod of pergol returning from
season to episode 15 the call and now
they are responding to the call from
Ezra they wipe out the fleet tentacles
smashing Through the Windows and
wrapping around thrawn charge enough to
jump into hyperspace
force will be with you always
in this way we come full circle with
bindu's prediction of thrawn's defeat in
the season 3 finale what what do you see
I see your defeat
defeat like many arms surrounding you in
a cold Embrace but is thrawn truly
defeated the Ahsoka series explores how
thrawn and Ezra follow these Pergo on
the path to paridia and thrawn's fate of
many arms surrounding him in a cold
Embrace may take on yet another meaning
at some point in the future let's also
not forget the evolutionary link between
wolves and whales the reason whales are
sea mammals is that in the distant past
there was a wolf ancestor who lived
close to water and lived more and more
of its life swimming eventually evolving
into whales they have a common ancestry
like Ezra and Kanan they are Kindred so
the rebels launch and blow up the base
they play a hollow recording from Ezra I
couldn't have wished for a better family
I can't wait to come home now we learned
in Ahsoka that Ezra recorded a longer
personal recording just for Sabine where
it sounded like he actually intended to
disappear how much time did he have to
record stuff so then we jump to an
epilogue that takes place after the
battle of Endor after Return of the Jedi
and mirroring the opening shot of the
series Sabine now leans on the railing
of the lothal comms Tower looking out
over the city but instead of a star
destroyer over her head it's ahsoka's T6
shuttle and x-wings a storyboard that
Dave filoni also reused for Ahsoka
episode 1. Sabine has cut her hair even
shorter and now her armor Bears a
pauldron with a pergol on it we find out
Zeb has taken kallus to Lira asan to
prove that the lasat species was not
extinct we learned that Hera fought in
the Battle of Endor Rex fought in the
Battle of Endor 2 and now she has a son
Jason sindula kanan's son Specter 7.
also similar framing to the shots of
Ahsoka episode 2 but I much preferred
this version Ahsoka wears white robes
and carries a staff which Dave filoni
intended to look like Gandalf the White
the incomplete Mentor returning to
someone who is further down the path of
a Enlightenment the two go off in search
of Ezra Bridger and end of series Ahsoka
begins with them on the other side of
that search Master and Apprentice
apparently having failed to connect but
you know what on its own this Rebels
finale is perfect it brings to an end
all of these characters arcs in such a
great way and he could tell Dave filoni
really wanted to stick that Landing
considering initially Clone Wars ended
in kind of this open-ended state so as
we walk away from Rebels let's get a
season 4 cheat sheet here must watch
episodes all of them especially season
four folks come on it's only 16 episodes
but if you only have time for some
definitely hit episode 10 Jedi Knight
episode 12 wolves in a door episode 13 a
world Between Worlds and episode 16 the
finale okay next the mortis gods are
Star Wars celestials who link with
mystical loathe wolves in some way to
open up the world Between Worlds a realm
that allows a kind of time travel in the
Star Wars universe and while the lothal
temple was destroyed that realm still
exists next the Jedi and Caleb Doom have
some mysterious history with lothal next
thrawn and Ezra were taken by the Pergo
through hyperspace to some mystery
destination next Wolves in general are
extremely important to Dave baloney into
Star Wars fiction and lastly the world
Between Worlds is described by Sabine as
a star map alright I want to thank you
so much for joining me on this Rebels
rewatch series it's been so rewarding to
do this please recommend these Rebels
recap videos to everyone you know who's
watching Ahsoka who just wants to know
what happened to Rebels but doesn't feel
like watching in all the episodes please
subscribe to all three channels of the
new rock stars Network you can follow me
at eavos thanks for watching I'll see
you next time bye
[Music]